[music]
All right, everyone. Thanks for joining
us. My name is Evan Hilda. I'm the head
of physical AI at Nebus. Uh I'm building
out a team that is working on some
services to really provide uh more
automated workflows in physical AI.
We're building out a control plane to
really run the entire data flywheel, if
you will, in physical AI from data
curation to training to evaluation to
inference and back again. The biggest
bottleneck we're seeing right now in the
space is evaluation, right? Does
[clears throat] the model do what we
think it's going to do? And can we
actively put it into the field? Can we
understand where the gaps are in our
model and our in our data sets? And uh I
met Antioch a few months ago. They are
by far the most impressive tool I've
seen for evaluation and robotics. So I
felt compelled to bring them here and
talk about it. Um can you give a quick
intro uh you your background what you've
been working on and then we'll go into
all things Antioch.
>> Certainly really appreciate that Evan.
Um hey everyone my name is Harry Melop
one of the co-founders of Antioch. Uh my
background I met my co-founding team all
at Stanford actually. We're all
undergrad and grad school there
together. I spent a bit of time on the
autopilot team at Tesla where I was
responsible for training machine
learning models that ran on the car and
also on the the humanoid robot Optimus.
Um I left to build my first company in
the national security space again
applying machine learning techniques to
track trace and sort of solve various
types of financial crime. Uh we sold
that company in 2023 and then I began
kind of working on Antioch with many of
the same team and that takes us to where
we are now.
>> Amazing. It's an awesome journey. So I
want to open up with a quote that you
said to me and I'm going to paraphrase
but this quote has stuck in my mind
incessantly the last few days. You said
that with things like cursor and clawed
code these agentic development tools
software engineering became a tailwind
from LLMs right and we've really tied
the software industry software
development industry to the intelligence
of models
>> but we're a long ways away from doing
that in the physical world. How can we
create a similar effect a similar
tailwind in the physical world?
>> Yeah, I think it's exactly exactly the
right question. So I think you know it
probably behooves us to sort of first
explore how that happened uh with with
cursor initially and then claude code
and now you know tools like factory and
cognition that have created this AI
software engineer and I think what's
kind of interesting is they've taken the
entire engineering cycle right like
being an engineer is a lot more than
writing code it and I think of it as
sort of this five-step process where you
start with the existing system you find
a problem you develop a hypothesis you
write some code, make changes, run
tests, learn from it, and and kind of
repeat. And in the world of software
engineering, that's all represented
fundamentally as code. LLMs, you know,
innately deeply understand that problem
domain. In the world of physical AI,
it's harder to reason about, you know,
if we make a change to that system, how
did that actually sort of impact the
performance overall, right? like if we
were to change a hardware component, if
we were to rewrite some software,
retrain a model, like how do we kind of
give the agent the ability to reason
about the quality of its own changes and
so I think we at Antioch think a lot
about this in terms of providing agents
with this idea of a verifier, right? So,
you know, where has AI been most
impactful? Like we've seen incredible
breakthroughs in mathematics, right? Uh
GPT 5.5 was able to crack an EDO
problem, you know, a month or so ago and
it's because in mathematics we've got a
verifier. If the agent makes a change,
it can immediately validate the efficacy
of that. In software, we compile, we run
the code, the same thing. And so at
Antioch, we think about bringing that
verification, which uh in our minds
boils down to sort of simulation as a
general domain. And we're not
opinionated about exactly what simulator
we use necessarily, but it's really this
problem space of like how do we give the
agent the ability to explore the
efficacy of its own change. It's a
combination of classical simulation of
world models of the ability to to author
changes across hardware, software,
firmware, and update models, retrain
models. Um, and I think that those sort
of pieces come together so that there's
this flywheel effect that ultimately
builds.
>> Amazing. So, I feel like when you drop
the word simulation here, half the
people just tune out,
>> right?
>> It's a very polarizing topic. A lot of
people don't believe in simulation. They
think the material gap is too large.
We're a ways away. is not good enough
fidelity. You've had to overcome that
quite a bit. I see the customers you
work with.
>> Yeah,
>> it's working in certain areas. What is
your go-to talk track to the skeptics
about simulation today?
>> It's a great question. I mean, I think
if we look at the domains in which
physical AI today is most scaled, it's
autonomous driving, right? Like we've
had a decade now of of sort of
autonomous driving improving
monotonically, getting better and
better, and today you can go and buy a
Tesla. If you're in the right city, you
go take a Whimo, it works pretty close
to flawlessly. And a key reason for that
is these companies have thought about
how to collapse their iteration cycle.
on simulation in its most general sense
whether that's a classical physical
simulator model likely a combination of
both today in many cases that provides
that feedback loop and it makes that
iteration velocity so quick so in sort
of leading areas of physical AI we've
seen simulation be deeply embraced uh it
stands to reason that that you know that
should kind of continue as we see the
proliferation of physical AI across
other industries uh the sort of question
that I think about is not can simulation
do this or not but rather what is the
cost of actually making that that
possible? Like how much work do we have
to put in for each given domain? Whether
it's a a drone or a dextrous humanoid,
you know, there's sort of different ends
of the spectrum of difficulty. Um, but
we sort of think about attacking that in
a very principled and disciplined way uh
with, you know, using autonomous driving
kind of as our northstar of what great
looks like in the limit there.
>> Totally. So, before we get into the
weeds of how you're solving some of
these problems, let's in let's inspire
people really quickly.
Fast forward 10, 20 years in the future,
Antioch's a massive success. What does
the developer experience look like when,
as you call yourselves, the cursor of
physical AI? And that's true. What does
a day in the life look like for
developer?
>> Yeah. No, it's it's a great question.
So, I think, you know, I look a lot at
how has software engineering changed
over the last few years and software
engineering has gone from, you know,
being incredibly down in the detail each
and every day to being much more intent
driven, right? Like now I think the
process of building has become much more
of establishing what that northstar what
great looks like whether that's you know
start with some test coverage start with
some sort of objective function and then
AI kind of does all of the work and
we've seen these massive speed ups and
it's collapsed the cost of software
right so I think you know it's a sort of
common refrain at the moment that
there's no moat in the world of of
software anymore um and I think you know
that that creates a lot of concern for a
lot of people but what's really exciting
about that is we going to have so much
more of it. The cost is reduced. And so
I think if we think about what that
plays out in the physical world, you
know, what are some of our biggest
societal challenges at the moment? We've
got runaway inflation. Uh we've got, you
know, sort of an increasingly uncertain
geopolitical environment where people
are looking for certainty and the way
that costs and availability of goods and
services is in a predictable way. And I
think that's the end case of this. I
think it is, you know, we can as a
society codify the intent behind the
systems that we're building and then
these sort of autonomous agents can go
off and actually deliver that uh in a
way that's just going to sort of
fundamentally change the way that we
live in a really positive way. I think
>> amazing. Let's dive into the platform a
little bit because I think you guys are
solving some of the hardest problems in
a really unique way. What exists now
with Antioch that either didn't exist
before or was just really hard to do
before, right? So for example, some of
the things you're doing with taking in
real world sensor data to calibrate the
virtual sensors, things like this.
>> Yeah. Uh totally. So I think I'd sort of
think about it on two halves. there's
like how do we attack the problem of
simulation fidelity and that's this you
know what we call the pair setting
process basically and that's where we
try to take the strengths of classical
physical simulation amazing tools from
some of our partners like Nvidia with
Isaac sim and and other types of
technologies there and also the
strengths of what we're seeing in the
sort of generative world right this
ability to close the sim toreal gap over
time using more and more data we bring
that together under one roof in the
platform without customers actually
having to think about that so when you
on forward into Antioch, you know, we're
sort of looking at your real world
deployments, automating that
calibration, and using kind of the best
of both worlds to collapse that. So
suddenly the fidelity of your simulation
is just so much better than it was
before. But what's more most exciting
about that really is not simulation for
the sake of simulation. Like what we
really care about is robots in the real
world, not simulating them, right? And
so it's then using that as the substrate
against which agents can kind of
engineer. So if you've got a 30 40
person engineering team or even larger,
you're now reinforcing them with agents
who are reasoning about your systems in
the same way that your engineers do just
as we've kind of seen factory and
cognition and some other amazing
companies do in the world of software
engineering.
>> Got it. So let's double click on the
symmetry gap a little bit like many
people have been trying to solve this
problem for a long time and they've
failed.
Why is this time different? And to tee
you up a bit more, you talked a little
bit about uh using like SIM as a machine
learning process less a development
process. Can you speak to that concept a
little bit?
>> Totally. Yeah. So, I mean I, you know,
hesitate to come back to the
self-driving idea, but I think it's
really relevant. And so, like, you know,
if we think about the history of
self-driving vehicles starting with, you
know, maybe like the DARPA Grand
Challenge, you know, decades ago now, it
was very much framed as a software
problem to start with. We're using
traditional computer science techniques
to try and save the uh to to solve this
problem. And I think what we ultimately
found is like over time, you know,
initially companies like Wave and now
this is very much a consensus opinion in
the world of self-driving is if you
reframe what was once a software problem
as a machine learning problem as a data
problem, you just get these
extraordinary compounding results and
you get this monotonicity in the
improvement of these systems. And I
think we think about simulation in very
much the same way, right? There are some
advantages to having classical software.
you get determinism, you get
repeatability, but there are also kind
of gaps that form just as there were
gaps that were forming in the world of
self-driving vehicles. And so by sort of
reframing this as a data problem and a
machine learning problem, we're able to
sort of systematically collapse many of
those gaps uh in a way that I think
we've seen, you know, leaders in in
other industries do in the past. And,
you know, to sort of make this kind of
concrete, like I think many people are
probably very familiar with with tools
like Nvidia Cosmos where you're able to
sort of do these domain shifts. We think
very much about that but in a multimodal
context right so if you've got a sort of
simulated camera image what does it take
to make that perfectly realistic you
train a model like cosmos but it's the
same with radar lidar infrared all these
different types of sensor modalities
that are really really important so we
need to have those kind of point
solutions available across the board and
that's what we're really focused on atte
Yeah.
>> Can you speak a little bit to one of the
advantages you guys were trying to
acrewue
>> in that once you see a sensor in a
certain context that's locked in?
>> Yeah.
>> And there's starting to be a
proliferation. Everyone's going to be
using similar sensors. They're going to
see similar lighting in similar context.
But once you have that, that gap is now
closed or closing over time. Can you
speak a little bit to how you guys are
doing that and what you're doing?
>> Yeah, definitely. So I think you know
there's the sort of plethora of hardware
components and there's also the plethora
of different environments that robots
are deployed into right and so you know
to sort of be concrete like maybe the
first time we see a given radar
component it's deployed on an AMR or an
AGV or something in a manufacturing
context but what we're observing in our
customer base is that you actually then
start to see those same chips deployed
on drones and so suddenly on drones
you're seeing different types of things
that you never saw before like weather
effects and rain and these things that
you don't experience experience inside a
warehouse. And so we use that kind of as
an opportunity to improve our
understanding of, you know, not just
that individual radar component, but
what does it mean to operate as a radar,
how does that work from a fundamental
sort of physical phenomena perspective
and layer those improvements into the
platform. So the next time, you know,
ideally we maybe see the same radar
component again and it's just a one
shot, like it's straight out of the box,
ready to go, perfectly calibrated for
our customers or maybe it's a little
different. Maybe it's a it's a slightly
new a newer model or something, but
we're sort of going from a a running
start, if you will, because we've solved
these these types of problems before.
>> That's awesome. That's compelling.
So, last question on the SIM to real
topic. Um, I want to sort of
create a framework or a scale for people
in terms of where it's easy.
>> Yeah.
>> Where it's hard but solvable and where
it's impossible.
across the customers you've worked with
and what you've seen where is it easy
and people here should just go do it
because it doesn't exist where is it
hard you got to just earn it
>> where is it impossible we need it need
some innovation so
>> yeah it's a great question so I think
again I come back to this idea of like
well where is simulation come from it's
come from a combination of the
self-driving space and actually of video
games in in many cases as well and so
where it's really strong today are those
areas of domain so sort of visual
fidelity light based sensors, these
types of things, particularly when you
add layers like cosmos and stuff on top
of the underlying sort of simulator. So
I think a lot about, you know, what is
physical autonomy? You can sort of boil
it down to this idea of like sense,
think, and act. The sense problem today,
we're really generally pretty good at.
And especially with this type of sort of
machine learning approach where we take
real customer data like to sort of train
each customer's you know individual
calibration models um you know the
fidelity of that sensing especially in
the light based domain radar camera
infrared these types of things is really
very good. I think where things get
harder is in the action space and so I
think again it just comes back to well
you know what did self-driving need?
What did video games need? They didn't
need the same degree of sort of physical
fidelity that we're now demanding out of
like complex dextrous tasks,
manipulation, deformables, these types
of things. So to me, it just comes down
again to like a question of cost. It's
not that we're not going to get there,
it's just that it's going to take more
data, more engineering time, more sort
of concerted effort to push there over
time. We're already seeing some of that.
Like we do we do deployments with you
know deformable things like cardboard
boxes and you know all sorts of stuff
that that that that's pretty tricky to
model material removal and manufacturing
processes and stuff as well. All of this
is possible. It's just simply a question
of prioritizing especially based on a
cost equation.
>> Got it.
So when customers embark on this
journey,
what's the most common failure mode you
see like as you're from the idea of
trying to figure out what to measure the
benchmarks, how to create the sim, what
failure modes exist along that I guess
hill climb towards a good simulation.
Yeah, I mean I think it's uh I I think
people often get trapped at sort of the
very first phase of like how do we even
sort of start to think and how do we
systematize about creating the digital
twin in the first place and the reality
is that if you go and you use an
off-the-shelf simulator today generally
it's going to start by not being very
effective at your task area like it's
not going to be well calibrated there's
some innate sim tore gap these tools are
really hard to use in the first place as
well so sort of even getting that very
first version of something that works
somewhat like your real system is
complicated. So we spend a lot of time
thinking about how we automate that for
our customers. And then I think sort of
about this long tail and and it's it's
the same long tail that we see in so
many other engineering problems, machine
learning type problems where okay, it's
working 85% of the time, but that's
unacceptable and you sort of slowly
wretch at the nines. And I think that's
really where framing this as a machine
learning problem is really helpful
because you can use some of the classic
techniques that we've pioneered in
machine learning like you can run your
high loss experiments and all of these
types of things to sort of
systematically uncover here is where
it's failing. Here's how we might
improve it. Here's the data that we need
to go out and collect to actually better
calibrate these systems. And you then
just start running a proper engineering
process that enables the sort of
monotonic strive towards like greater
fidelity and improvement over time. But
if you sort of that first phase is is
really very tricky and we spend a lot of
time thinking about how we automate
that.
>> Got it. So almost last question as we
land the plane here. Um
the holy grail is a closed loop and like
continuous learning.
>> And there's a lot you can do in your
platform to do eval but to go train the
model. Yes.
>> And to go deploy the model on the robots
to put the data back in the customer's
own data lake. there's lots of other
environments and tools that have to be
pulled into this.
>> What's missing today for you guys and
for your customers to close that loop?
Yeah.
>> And bring all those tools into one
unified system.
>> It's a great question. Um, you know, I
think for us within Antioch by itself
today, you can change the hardware
components, you can change some of the
software, but I think to your point,
thinking about the life cycle of how we
retrain a model, right? Like how do we
custody the data? how do we think about
our training data splits and like how we
do fine-tuning and all these types of
processes that's something that we don't
do today in Antioch and I think it's
like that's why we're excited to be
working together right like um I think
you know as we sort of deepen uh the
integrations between Antioch and and and
Nebius and the sort of physical AI
workbench and these types of things is I
think the missing link uh today and
we'll sort of see more and more of this
autonomous engineering cycle over time
>> and that's our that's our teaser for the
audience that that's the problem we're
we're working on and so
>> if you want to learn more talk to us
after about how we're doing it. Um,
I guess one last question that's a
little more philosophical and maybe
personal, um, I end every podcast I do
with this same question, which is,
as humans, as we look at this
exponential liftoff, right, a lot of
change is going to happen. The world's
going to get weird. I'm still not used
to seeing robots walking around. It
still kind of freaks me out, even though
I'm trying to bring it into the world.
>> Yeah. Um,
but as we try to prepare for this future
either as individuals,
as a society to best thrive in it,
what do you think is the most important
question we should be asking ourselves
to elicit the right conversation and
best prepare? Yeah, I think across the
board if you're building a company or if
you're, you know, an employee or just
operating in the world generally,
I think people need to really be
thinking a lot about how you tie, you
know, what you are focused on, what you
are building to the sort of underlying
and exponential growth in the
intelligence layer of these models. And
I think that's why, you know, companies
like factory and cognition have been so
successful is it allows software
companies to do exactly that. It's like,
okay, it's big and scary. It's getting
very cheap to write software that could
be perceived to be a threat and and
maybe it is a threat in certain areas.
But if you're able to sort of refactor
or rethink the way that you build
whatever it is that you're interested in
to become a tailwind on the sort of
model intelligence layer.
That's all but certain at this point
that you know that the intelligence is
improving. There's interesting questions
about whether it will become superhuman.
at very least it's going to reduce the
sort of cost of intelligence close to
zero over time. Uh and I think you want
to be attached as a tailwind to sort of
ultimately how you think about that.
>> Perfect. Full circle from our first
conversation. Our our talk about closed
loop learning was the loop was closed.
>> It's self closed loop. Yeah.
>> Uh so basically what you're saying is
like
>> you got to trust fall into these models.
Yes. Yes. And like ride the wave and
expect the advances to come and be
>> not just living on the edge, living
ahead of the edge, expecting them to
catch up,
>> the wave to kind of catch you and just
all the touch points throughout the
organization, everything that you build,
how you operate, the the entire kind of
shebang being sort of very attached to
that.
>> Amazing.
>> Well, I think it's a good place to end.
If you want to learn more about how
we're closing the loop together, come
chat with us afterwards. And uh thank
you guys for your attention and time.
>> Awesome. Thanks, everyone. Thanks, Evan.